moins de 40 minutes et puissant va
aucune image de Noël le grecte
d'infiltrer ce matin seul ce communiqué
de la FFF
la démission de l'homme à sa tête depuis
la fédération est l'une des fédérations
les mieux gérés donc partout il est
passé
ses institutions qu'il a eu à diriger
ces clubs il a dirigé en connu le succès
et je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
critiques mais les résultats de la
Fédération Française depuis 11 ans se
remarquables qui devrait probablement
être nommé à la direction du bureau
parisien de la FIFA je pense qu'il y a
tous les ingrédients dans cette affaire
pour susciter au mieux de la curiosité
et au pire une forme de voyeurisme
Fresnes illustre à elle seule le
problème de la surpopulation carcérale
des détenus qui cohabitent dans des
cellules exigues et complètement vétuste
rare cafard et punaises de lit complète
un tableau peu reluisant
c'est quand même incroyable le nombre
d'experts autoproclamés que l'on voit
défiler sur les plateaux de télévision
dont le vôtre d'ailleurs connaisse le
droit qui sont avocats qui sont dans le
droit j'entends bien que l'on soit connu
ou pas impossible en effet d'échapper au
choc carcéral ressenti lors de son
entrée en prison une règle à laquelle
freine ne fait pas exception oh je suis
toujours très circonspect quand je vois
des professionnels de la justice venir
parler de dossiers qui ne sont pas les
leurs juste pour rebondir la salle du
chiffrer quelqu'un qui est addict à la
drogue le maître en prison c'est juste
une folie parce que c'est l'endroit où
il y a le plus où il y a le plus de
drogues mais madame la Première ministre
le mensonge le suffira pas on ne
gouverne pas la France seule contre tous
votre isolement ne peut vous conduire
qu'à une seule chose vous allez craquer
le 7 mars le pays sera à l'arrêt et ce
n'est qu'un début un certain nombre de
professions sont déjà prêtes pour le 7
et au-delà du 7 c'est le cas à la SNCF
mais c'est aussi le cas dans les IOG ou
évidemment les militants discutent des
formes d'action mais en tout cas la
détermination ils ont pas besoin de
Martinez pour l'avoir et seul compagnons
de voyage que nous avons vu dans cette
hémistique sont les compagnons de la
France insoumise ça s'appelle
l'obstruction l'obstruction pour
empêcher le débat ça s'appelle
l'imprécision pour montrer que vos
possessions ne tiennent pas la route ça
s'appelle l'irresponsabilité avec une
proposition de contre-réforme qui
coûterait 90 milliards d'euros par an à
200 mètres de hauteur dans le ciel de la
défense
cette grue pendouille dans le vide
ballotée au gré du vent et puis Guy
Savoie perd sa troisième étoile un coup
de tonnerre dans le milieu de la
gastronomie le guide Michelin a décidé
de lui retirer hier même sanction pour
le chef Christopher Coutances qui perd
sa troisième étoile également et Michel
Saran qui lui va perdre sa deuxième
étoile mettez-vous à ma place après un
an et demi de dépression mais vous
rendez compte comment vous cogitez comme
un homme peut cogiter avec ses équipes
quand il y a eu la peur de l’étoile je
veux faire en sorte de fermer et je les
veux plus hier après-midi
des salariés du quartier la voix
s'effondrer
à la pliée avec le vent il y avait
quelqu'un dans la grue ils ont réussi à
évacuer la personne oui ça fait mal oui
j'aurais préféré qu'on me dise qu'un
inspecteur me dise après un repas mais
voilà là j'ai pas fait un bon repas je
vous explique pourquoi et qu'on en
discute ok un échange une autre métier
c'est du partage on partage avec les
clients là c'est pas un partage c'est
une 5 secondes jusqu'à présent je ne
vais connu que des meilleurs moments
dans ma carrière on a perdu le match
cette année mais on va le regagner
l'année prochaine
Berck-sur-Mer hier soir la valse des
aurores boréales sous l'objectif des
photographes
les passionnés étaient de sortie dans le
Pas-de-Calais ou pour capturer le
Mont-Saint-Michel et la banquise de
l'Antarctique n'a jamais été aussi
réduite fin février l'étendue de glace a
atteint la superficie la plus faible
jamais enregistrée depuis le début des
relevés satellites en 1979 un phénomène
que seul les photographes chevronnés
avec un long temps de pause parviennent
à révéler l'auteur de ce cliché a réussi
hier soir la banquise mesure aujourd'hui
un million 790000 km² contre 2 millions
il y a un an